après vingt ans de loyaux et bon service
dans la direction de communication de
plusieurs entreprises frédéric suquet a
choisi le pari de l'entrepreneuriat pour
cela rien de tel que sa passion la
course à pied il a choisi d'ouvrir une
franchise du magasin et run à conflans
sainte honorine
j'ai commencé la course à pied à l'âge
de 12 ans je suis fils d'un ancien
sprinteur qui a couru avec les meilleurs
français
je suis frère d'un marathonien qui a
fait partie des meilleurs français
également donc on est vraiment une
famille de deux coureurs on aime le
sport
l'ouverture de ce magasin permet de
pouvoir allier ce désir d'entreprendre
et cette passion pour la course à pied
frédéric suc échos régulièrement depuis
de nombreuses années sur piste sur route
se testant même omar à tous son
expérience lui donne une expertise pour
conseiller ses clients proposent des
produits adaptés à la course à pied à la
marche indique outre elle parce que la
force d'un magasin spécialisé comme le
mien le dicton d'autres
notre raison d'être c'est être
spécialiste ne s'invente pas quand on
vend des chaussures par exemple à un
client en vivant en fonction de sa
morphologie en fonction de sa foulée en
fonction du terrain sur lequel il va
courir ce besoin de conseils est
d'autant plus justifiée qu'en france le
running devient une activité physique
très populaire la course à pied qui est
devenu vraiment un business qui marche
c'est un mauvais jeu de mots puisque au
début des années 2000 il y avait en
france à peu près de deux millions de
pratiquants
aujourd'hui on sait que les chiffes
tourne autour de 15 millions de
pratiquants en france
malheureusement pour le gérant le second
confinement le force à fermer ses portes
un paradoxe étant donné que le premier
avait fait de nombreux adeptes à la
course à pieds et jambes on continue à
courir
le running et le sport enfin le sport en
plein air on va dire on n'en a jamais
autant entendu parler depuis depuis
l'apparition de ce virus
une décision difficile à accepter pour
le jeune entrepreneur qui doit également
interrompre les sessions de running man
group qui l'organisent devant sa
boutique tous les lundis soirs